hi
welcome to my talk about browser and web
security and how it evolved over time
as you see it's called we're struggling
to keep up so
first of all something very brief about
me my name is frederick
and as jed already said i work for
mozilla in berlin
um i have an email address and so on if
you are that interested in it
but why am i here well i want to make
the web a bit more secure and
i hope i can do this by educating you a
bit more about security and make you a
bit more sensitive about this
so as it reads here in the mozilla
manifesto principle number five
um i think that individuals security and
privacy on the internet are fundamental
and they must not be treated as optional
so let's dive in what am i going to talk
about i'll give you a quick introduction
and then i will go through past present
or future of security features
which are implemented in the browser for
you as application developers
um so first of all the web and the
browser um
i work for mozilla and everybody says
and keeps on saying in meetings and big
meetings and the web is the platform
i get to hear it every day and it it's
true i mean the web is of course not
going away
and it's becoming more and more
feature-rich so
i don't know if you recall html4
or i mean html stands for hypertext
right which is
text linking to text yeah that's not
what the web is like today
um the web is experienced through rich
applications like gmail twitter facebook
and there's a neat graph that shows how
web apis have developed this is a
screenshot from evolution of the web
and i don't need you to read all of this
because it's really small
but the high level picture you should
get is it has
developed and evolved a lot
so for example there is html5 of course
which contains stuff like canvas full
screen
xml http request2 and all these things
that you need for
rich applications on the web um
and that of course leaves us with it
with a topic
um crosshat scripting um
and crosshat scripting is actually like
the buffer overflow was in the 1990s
in the 1990s every application or most
server side
application was more or less vulnerable
to some sort of buffer overflow
vulnerability
but since 2007 the most common
vulnerability in applications
seen overall vulnerabilities are
cross-set scripting applications
and that's not because um
that's not for an arbitrary reason it is
because the most popular applications
are web applications um and that doesn't
just leave us with a tiny alert box or
somebody stealing your cookies
in your desktop browser it's also in
your phone
on your tv and maybe even on the plane
if you used to come here
and given all these api rich html5
application platforms
and browser extensions and chrome apps
crossout scripting is much more than
just this
tiny alert box but it's actually some
way to control
all these devices hopefully not a plane
though um
but it could make your car stop or you i
do know it can make your phone ring
because well there are phones which do
that
so um let's go on and talk about the
past
of browser security i want to talk about
authentication authorization
um https and frames first of all let's
recap
http used to be stateless right you
issue a request
to a server and you get a response and
then you may do that again
and you get another response and the
server doesn't even know who you are and
it doesn't care it doesn't retain state
and would probably not even remember
that you're the same person as
previously
um this was solved with cookies as you
hopefully all know and the server
generates some sort of id and you keep
on sending it to the to the server so
the server is able to keep track who you
are
and what you're doing especially for
sessions and logins
but one of the problems here is
everything is sent in the clear
it is sent over plain text and if you're
using a public wi-fi
for example in a coffee shop or
something it basically exposes all the
authentication data
and even more possibly other
confidential stuff like bank statements
so as we all know the solution to that
is https
which some people say it's expensive but
i want to say it is really not
i have a website and i use it for
non-web application purposes
and i have a https way to get in there
because there are certificate
authorities that give you certificates
for free
and also google will rank you higher if
you're using https on your website
instead of just http
um what https satellite is not solving
is that it's opt in
right whenever you type in domain
without the protocol it will go to http
and not https
um and that is even more or less
undetected right the user isn't supposed
to observe whether there's a lock or a
no lock or a globe or a green lock or
something
something completely different so
and also https doesn't provide any
guarantees to the full content of the
web page right you may include images
from other servers
or ads or widgets or whatever and they
may not be loaded over https
so not everything is protected with
https we'll come back to this
but first i want to introduce you to
something you may have heard of
which is called the same origin policy
so in 1996 when javascript was invented
and frames
um the idea was to have some sort of
mashups in the web and include something
as
well let's say as a component in your
web page and that means reusing existing
code which is always a good idea
um but it was soon realized that it may
be a bad idea if you are included
if you're able to include something on a
web page and read everything that is
within it just imagine going to a
webpage
that frames your bank statements for
example and reads them
so of course this is forbidden and it
was realized that we shouldn't allow
that
from other domains wait no not domains
but origins
um so you have to be on the same origin
and what is an origin
well an origin is basically more than
just the domain it's
the scheme and the host and the port
of the url and we take that as a
criterion
to compare two things basically the
frame the inner frame the outer frame
so just to make it a bit more clear i
want to walk through a few examples
and i want this to be an interactive
part so please nod or shake your head if
you agree or disagree so i'm going to
say first
this is the same origin we'll always
compare the top right
um example.com over http and there's
another url in
url in the table i hope it's big enough
what do you think is it the same origin
please not or shake your head
a lot of people are nodding of course it
is the same origin
um what about this one https exactly
everybody's shaking their head https is
not http
and what about the port right http is
using a different port than https
um so what about this one
about blank well the domain is not blank
right is the bottom domain
no what's the port what are we doing
here what do you guys think
some people shake their head a lot of
non that courageous people not doing
anything okay i will reveal it for you
um
it is in this case actually mostly
allowed
so if you frame something that is
pointing to about blank or if you open a
pop-up
to about blank you have dom access
granted using javascript by writing
stuff in it or
reading stuff out of it because
everything that is in there
is basically has basically probably been
written by you or it's just an empty
page i mean what dangerous thing is
there to read right
it's really not going to contain your
banks bank statements
um what about the next one here
yeah i see a thumbs down there um yeah
the thing is i've been tricking you a
bit
um internet explorer for example does
not care about the port
and if you change document domain to
some other value in javascript
um all other browsers will also
basically stop looking at ports
um so to summarize the same origin
policy
um it is not as strict as we think um
it's a bit weird and it behaves
differently for a dom access
and ht xml http request for example you
wouldn't do an xml http request
to about blank for example um
so yeah there's not just one same origin
policy but there are multiple
scenarios you have to take into account
even though in general the policy just
says
poor domain scheme um
and there are also so many bypasses
right you can opt out of the same origin
policy using course
cross-origin resource sharing and then
there is jsonp
which is basically a hack that is meant
to bypass
the same origin policy which i by the
way don't recommend you to use
so if you want to learn more about the
same origin policy and how it's weird
i can uh suggest you look at one of
these talks
first one is by brent and ike called the
same origin saga from 2012.
the other one is from me because i had
to write a very long thesis
at my university about the same origin
policy which was
presented at absec research 2013 in
hamburg
but we'll come back to the topic of
frames and how other domains interplay
with your
web application but let's go on to the
present
i want to talk about https again and
about frames
so to solve the thing that https was
really just opt-in
there is something called http strict
transport security
um https was invented in 1994
and this year is from 2012 so we have
finally realized that it's a bad idea
to have https opt-in um
so there is a way to enforce that the
browser will always use https no matter
if the
person sitting in front of the browser
types in https or just the domain name
and it works like that usually you do
start off with http
and you and the client sends a request
the server response
hopefully forwarding to https and then
once an https channel has established
the server is allowed to send a header
that is called
strict transport security it comes with
the time to live and basically says
hey browser please cache this for a
certain amount of time
and whenever this time has not elapsed
continue using https when you talk to me
um that's neat right so the browser will
now
always use https but what about this one
it's plain text again what is what if
there's a network attacker that is
basically just
stripping off the forward to https
and what if i tell you there are a lot
of tools out there which
are really easy to use which are just
doing that they set up a proxy
everything is going through for you fine
and the user isn't actually using https
if they are again for example in the
coffee shop
so to fill even this gap there is a
preload list in modern browsers and
actually firefox and chrome basically
share the implementation of the list and
synchronize
and this preload list basically contains
the bit here um
let's cache this kind of thing so the
browser will always use https without
requiring the first
strict transport security header but
this list we have in the browsers
well they are opt-in because we can't
force other web applications into
supporting https of course
so to fill this list um a security
engineer
adam langley working at google on https
things went around conferences security
conferences and other conferences and
said
hey people do you want to be on that
list it's awesome it's secure it's
better than what you have right now
just send me an email and you know this
method to maintain
to maintain the list it scaled because
nobody sent him an email
um yeah you're laughing i find that
actually rather sad
so until just last month when they set
up a google form so
i hope the mails coming in have either
increased or you just got bored
maintaining the list manually
but now there's a google form you can do
it in a more automated way
but yeah still if you're using web
applications and if you're providing
them to somebody
and if you're already using https please
consider
using strict transport security in your
headers as well as sending us an email
and to get into the preload list
so now i will come back to frames um
so the thread model here i want to talk
about is basically your website being
framed by an evil website
so other than what we have before um
somebody like an innocent user clicks on
link goes to
goes to website and the website is evil
and is trying to hack something
and it does include an iframe that is
pointing to your website so he's
clicking around things
and i'm you may have heard about this
this is called click checking by the way
so there's like a like a non-transparent
thing
an opaque thing on top so he thinks he's
clicking on your game or something
but actually he's clicking on the on
your website and i don't know liking
stuff
um and there are much more evil things
an attacker can do when they
frame your website um here's the funny
thing
from when the user is using internet
explorer
so this meta tag is basically forcing
forcing the browser
into an archaic rendering mode and
legacy code
and probably also or potentially at
least legacy vulnerabilities
so that means whenever somebody's going
into a website that contains this meta
tag
ie will say oh this is an old website i
have to be backwards compatible so i
will use rendering modes from internet
explorer seven which is
about seven years old um and of course
this is inherited to what frames so if
somebody goes to a website that is
framing your website and they contain
this meta tag
well your website will totally behave
differently
which is potentially bad but it will
definitely look bad
and there is more we can do with frames
i don't know if you've seen xss filters
and know how that works so i'll recap
about that but a crosshair scripting
filter built into the browser
can help an attacker and so let's see
how do they work
the cross-site fill sorry the cross-site
scripting filter is looking at the
request
as well as the response and if there's
something that looks like an attack for
example a script tag that has been
smuggled into the web page
the filter will say hey this script is
exactly what has been in the response
and i'm pretty sure this is an attack
so i'll remove it or modify it so it
isn't really passed
as a script and the user's secure which
is fine
but what if there was some static html
or javascript that is in your web page
which somebody fakes as if it was in the
response but doesn't have any value
for the web application basically making
up a fake parameter
and sending it to the server the server
doesn't really work with it it just
ignores it because it's unknown and fake
but the browser will think hey this is
the same i'm going to remove it
yeah so what if this was a security
feature huh
so the solution to all these problems is
basically disallow framing
you probably don't want your website to
be framed why would you
um the key is to just send a header with
all your http responses that says x
frame options
deny if you do need framing sometimes
you can also pass in different other
options that might be useful for me
allow from
or same origin and luckily you all know
what same origin means now right
so this framing thing um is basically a
security problem we've been having for
12 years
the first concerns were raised in 2002
the header itself was implemented in
2008 but the rfc was actually only
published last year
and there is much much more an evil
person could do to your website and to
the users of your website
if you allow it to be displayed in the
frame i actually wrote a very long paper
and a blog post with a friend of mine
about it
um there would be link in the slides
when i published them so if you're
interested in that
kind of nifty list of attacks i
recommend you look into that
other than that i want to jump forward
into the future of browser security
features
i will have to talk about frames again
um i also want to mention cross-site
scripting in general and how we
can get the rid of it for once and for
all and i want to talk about content
delivery networks
which are so useful for our web pages so
first of all how would we include
untrusted content on our websites
where the thread model is here we have
to show something which is
maybe a user upload or something from a
third-party domain where we can't really
control what it's doing but we want to
show it
um like i don't know a like button or
something or in general things that has
been sent over http because well a man
in the middle
some and that some network attacker
could mess with it
um and we all know that crosshat
scripting even just in the frame can
change the whole website and redirect
the browser to something else
so to explain what we're going to do to
solve this i have to introduce you to
the principle of
not so much authority the idea is to
give frames access to the things that
are only really necessary
and to explain what i mean in system
security theory we are talking about the
principle of least authority
which means an actor should only have
access to
all resources that it needs but nothing
more just
the least possible resources but least
authority
in a browser world is kind of weird it
has actually been proven that html5 and
css3
without javascript are too incomplete so
i wouldn't say least authority anyway to
solve this there's a neat feature called
iframe sandbox and this really tiny
attribute just in your iframes
makes it really safe by default it
forbids scripts
it disallows forwarding and navigation
of the outer window
um no forms no plugins
and no matter what the actual origin is
of the content of the frame with regards
to the outer window it is considered as
a unique
and different origin no matter what they
are in real life
um and if you want to mess with a
sandbox and you do need scripts or
plugins or something
you can make it a bit weaker um i'm not
going through all the keywords it's
quite straightforward
um let's go and talk about cross-site
scripting and fixing once
once and for all who here knows about
csp
who is using csp yes um
that's the problem right nobody is
but there are great introductions to how
to make it work for your web application
without having to rewrite everything
so there are two really good talks i
recommend you look into if you're
interested in
adopting towards content security policy
first one is just last year mike west
and it was referenced
multiple times throughout the day just
by tim who stood here previously before
me
um so mike's talked towards the post
access as world explains csp in a very
very long and comprehensive way
and really interesting a colleague of
mine mark goodwin
went to steelcon in sheffield just a few
months ago and basically
tried to focus on the parts not how csp
works and how it's supposed to work but
how to make it work for you how to make
sure that your web application is more
secure
without having to mess and rewrite all
the other the full web application
basically providing a few developer
tools as well
um so due to timing constraints i just
want to say look into these talks they
are really good
it doesn't make any sense for me to
repeat something that has been really
well explained before
so as i said i do want to talk about
content delivery networks where speed
might trump security right
because you include a script from
something
that's not really under your control and
if you're paranoid enough
you may not really like it but it's
highly convenient right
there is basically something that is
most likely already in the browser cache
of the users which are using a website
because other people are using the same
content delivery network
so your website is faster and that is
nice you want to have this
but what if somebody changes the file
well that means they can
execute script on your web page and
change everything and due to the same
origin policy
it doesn't mean just for this web page
but for all web pages in the same origin
because
control so
the plan is or the idea for the future
is to lock it down with something that's
called sub resource integrity
this is yet to be a w3c specification
it's not completely done yet
and we are really looking for feedback
so but this is how it looks like
um it doesn't look really pretty but
what you do is basically you compute a
hash
of the file you intend to include and if
the file changes
well you just don't load it um
problem might be well if jquery doesn't
work the whole web application doesn't
work that's
unfortunate i would guess so we have a
fallback mechanism
of course it doesn't look much more
pretty but it works like that there is a
non-canonical source which is basically
the fast bit which is likely to be in
the cache
and it's being tried to load by the
browser and the browser does all the
checks for you of course it loads the
script
and checks if the hash matches which is
actually very very likely
but if it does if it doesn't match well
the website isn't just going to break
it's just going to use the source from
your domain which is probably not in the
cache probably not as fast but which can
ensure that your website
keeps on working so as i said feedback
is really appreciated towards sub
resource integrity we can also talk
about it later after my talk
this is at an early stage there is much
more into it i don't want to go through
all the details but if you think about
using cdns
this may be an option for you
so now i already want to conclude and
say that the browser
can help your web application there are
even more improvements on the horizon
like exam like for example sub resource
integrity
and even though the web evolved like
this which
i as a paranoid security person might
want to call chaotic
um browser security has kind of evolved
like this
there were some basic security checks in
the front like we are providing
encryption
same origin fine cross origin r um
there are cookies and that kind of work
and then the web
as a platform as a rich applications
platform was adopted
large scale right between 1995 and now
everybody's basically using a website
for something
um so yeah maybe we shouldn't just put
the patches and bug fixes for security
on top and try to think about it
when developing new things this is what
i propose but anyway
if you're concerned about your website
because of x-frame options and strict
transport security and all these things
there's a really nice dashboard which
has been developed by my colleague
stefan alvins
it basically gives you a nice overview
of the simple security features
and um if your website looks rather red
than green
then don't feel too bad these are
results from some mozilla web pages so
thank you very much for listening if you
have any questions i will be at the
mozilla hack lounge in the second floor
after this talk i don't think there will
be time for questions
thanks a lot for listening
you